quand un produit est très populaire il
peut vite disparaître des tablettes mais
vous allez voir que certaines pénuries
sont aggravées par des opportunistes qui
en profitent pour s'enrichir à nos
dépens
[Musique]
mais avant 2020 sony lance sa toute
nouvelle console de jeux vidéo la
Playstation 5
c'est la folie les gens se battent pour
la voir
après son lancement la console est
toujours aussi populaire
j'ai toujours été un petit peu gamer si
on veut pour les jeux vidéo et mes
enfants aussi
Vincent Dupuis est un entrepreneur dans
l'âme l'automne dernier il a combiné ces
deux passions et il a ouvert son propre
centre de jeux vidéo on a 46 stations
avec un ordinateur les composantes puis
on a on a 8 switch de Nintendo on a
trois ps5 bah c'est sûr que nous on
voulait offrir la fine pointe avec
falaise nécessairement inclure la
Playstation 5 dans notre offre mais
c'était pratiquement introuvable Best
Buy Walmart les grandes chaînes sont
constamment en rupture de stock j'ai
élargi dans mes recherches en ligne j'ai
été voir aux États-Unis j'étais voir un
peu partout on a trouvé quelqu'un qui
qui le vendait sur ebay 899 Canadiens
plus 89 d'expédition
pour trois consoles Vincent a payé une
surenchère de 1000 dollars par rapport
au prix en magasin qui en profite les
revendeurs comme le jeune Britannique
Jack Baileys
en vous empêchant d'acheter vos biens au
vrai prix de vente il met la main sur
les produits avant tout le monde à
l'aide d'une arme redoutable des robots
d'achat
afin de savoir comment fonctionne ces
robots nous allons à Toronto pour
rencontrer l'entrepreneur Louis Eric
Simard nous l'avons sollicité en raison
de ses talents de programmer robot c'est
le vieux terme de science-fiction qui
voulait dire simplement travailler c'est
tout simplement un logiciel qui calcule
le plus près possible le comportement
d'un humain qui ferait exactement la
même chose à la différence près qui le
fait beaucoup beaucoup plus rapidement
Louis
eric a programmé pour nous un robot
d'achat sur une boutique fictive pour ne
pas avoir à le faire sur un vrai site
donc on a ici un site en seulement
affectif de la facture qui vend une
Playstation
il lance le robot en action alors
l'automate va tout simplement à rajouter
ici l'item au panier en cliquant sur HD
au panier et à la fin va passer à la
casse et remplir toute l'information et
passer la commande en réalité le robot
est beaucoup plus rapide que dans notre
exemple ça prend une fraction de seconde
une fraction de seconde et on va passer
la commande et ce pour un site qui
verrait cette transaction le passé elle
serait essentiellement identique à celle
qu'un humain avait
une personne sur quatre qui navigue sur
internet est en fait un mauvais robot et
les ratio augmente d'année en année
ils servent à acheter toutes sortes de
produits comme le constate Jacques
Nantel qui étudie le commerce
électronique depuis le début de ce
phénomène ça peut toucher des produits
aussi banals que des produits
alimentaires que les produits
électroniques des jeux vidéo ça peut
aller même dans les meubles c'est
lorsqu'on sent que le produit va être en
rupture de stock ou que le produit va
devenir rare à trouver
tout ce qui est un forte demande comme
des couvertures chauffantes ou des
friteuses à air les revendeurs
s'adaptent aux nouvelles tendances
à certains égards c'est le Far West je
siphonne tout ce qui est chez les
détails chez les walmarts
à l'unité parce que pas les
consommateurs trouvent plus souvent 20%
30% des fois 100% plus cher quand il va
être prête à payer n'importe quel prix
pour l'obtenir les thèmes qui est rare
je m'attendais pas à faire face à un
défi de la sorte pour me procurer un
produit qui est pas particulier ou niche
nous avons contacté des grands
détaillants qui vendent la Playstation 5
pour savoir ce qu'ils font contre les
robots d'achat
Best Buy nous répond que les robots sont
un problème généralisé à l'ensemble de
l'industrie et explique avoir mis en
œuvre des mesures pour limiter leur
répercussions
Walmart aussi travaille lors du
lancement de la PlayStation 5 Walmart
affirme avoir bloqué 20 millions de
transactions faites par des robots en 30
minutes l'entreprise dit continuer
d'apprendre et d'optimiser ces systèmes
les gens sont ingénieux c'est toujours
un le jeu d'échec avec une nouvelle
technique il y a une nouvelle réponse
c'est le cas des capshats les tests qui
servent à prouver à l'ordinateur que
nous sommes des humains les programmeurs
savent très bien comment les déjouer on
va embaucher des gens ou ça coûte
vraiment pas cher de l'art briser les
ketchups à répétition alors ça coûte une
fraction de sous c'est ce que propose
des entreprises basées en Inde par
exemple un travailleur qui résout 1000
Capsa va gagner moins d'un dollar en
2023 je vois pas l'intérêt d'avoir des
ketchups pour cette transactionnelle ces
systèmes là servent plus embêter le
consommateur qui a résoudre quelques
problèmes que ce soit
certains créateurs de robots qui ont le
sens des affaires vendent leur programme
à d'autres revendeurs il me propose même
des abonnements mensuels qui donnent
accès à différents services
est-ce qu'il faut être un génie
d'informatique pour utiliser des robots
d'achat tellement pas il faut savoir
allumer l'ordinateur et suivre les
instructions mais c'est accessible à
tout le monde on n'est pas à la fin des
robots d'achat absolument pas
aussi étonnant que ça puisse paraître
l'usage de robot d'achat est bel et bien
légal
seule exception des robots pour revendre
des biais de spectacle pour les autres
produits c'est carte blanche
et c'est pas demain qu'on va commencer à
changer les lois pour
poursuivre des intermédiaires qui
prennent des positions abusées sur des
produits de consommation tels que les
PlayStation
la Playstation c'est une chose mais des
services essentiels c'en est une autre
aux États-Unis des robots ont bloqué des
rendez-vous de renouvellement de
passeport pour ensuite les revendre
autre exemple le lait maternisé qui a
connu de graves problèmes
d'approvisionnement une enquête
américaine est en cours pour déterminer
si les robots ont contribué à la pénurie
lorsqu'on commence à jouer avec des
produits pharmaceutiques des produits
alimentaires là on a vraiment un
problème d'éthique profond il ne faut
pas que les consommateurs acceptent ça
il faut il faut le dénoncer qui dans
toute la chaîne est pénalisé selon vous
par l'utilisation de ça toujours le
client final
le seul intérêt de mettre un robot de
revente et légitime c'est d'augmenter le
prix les revendeurs sont là pour rester
mais Vincent espère souvenirs Sony va
leur couper l'herbe sous le pied en
produisant un nombre suffisant de
PlayStation il faut qu'il soit certain
qu'il est capable de desservir son
marché je pense que ça ça réglerait déjà
beaucoup de problèmes
j'espère qu'ils vont s'en aligner leurs
flûtes pour la PlayStation 6
[Musique]
aux États-Unis il y a un projet de loi
pour tenter dans Diguer le phénomène
mais rien au Canada sauf pour les
billets spectacles donc les revendeurs
ont beau jeu et n'ont rien à craindre